جريمه مروعه هزت النمزه لابن سجن ابنته في
قبوي منزله واغتصبها لمده 24 عاما متواصله
وانجب منها سبعه اطفال فقد قام جوزيفر
بسجن ابنته الى البالغه من العمر 18 عاما
واخدع زوجته والشرطه بانها هربت للانضمام
الى طائفه دينيه
يعود مسرح الجريمه المروء الى عام 2018
عندما اخبرت الى زباله الشرطه اثناء
ذهابها الى المستشفى في بلده امستتن
بالنمسا ان والدها احتجزها وانها انجبت
منه سبعه اطفال ظل ثلاثه منهم في الاسر مع
والدتهم وتوفي اخر بعد ولادته بوقت قصير
حيث قام السفاح النمساوي بالتستر على اثار
جريمته واخبر الشرطه ان اليزابيث هربت الى
طائفه دينيه في التاسع والعشرين من اغسطس
عام
1984 وهو اليوم الذي خدررها فيه وسحبها
الى زنزانته حيث قام هو وزوجته روزماري
بتربيه الباقي بعد زعمه لقد ظهروا على
عتبه ما به
[موسيقى]
حكم على بريتز بالسجن المؤبد بعد اقراره
بارتكاب جرائم الاغتصاب والسجن الباطل
والقتل بسبب الاهمال والسفاح القربى في
مارس عام 2009 وفي تطورات هذه الجريمه
المروعه تم شراء منزل المجرم النمساوي او
بيت الرعب كما اطلق عليه في الوسائل
الاعلام المحليه من قبل مالكين جديدين
وقسماه الى شقق مؤجره لشباب بعد فشل خطط
تحويله الى متحف الرعب